hello everyone this next game I'm about
to show you is probably one of garriga's
par with most famous games it was played
in 1999 in the Vikings in Netherlands
and although probably every channel on
YouTube already covered this game there
is quite a story to this game and I will
try to present it as such
so Garak as part of his white and he's
playing against Veselin Topalov so cuz
power plays efore and already we have
quite a surprise in the first move
topalov plays d6 the purse defense and
this was quite a quite a surprise to
Kasparov because well this isn't
something to Paolo usually plays but he
played it to avoid any opening
preparations by Kasparov so this is a
neither player really used this in
tournament play and it's not really an
opening one would use in such a high
high tournament so as power plays d4 we
have a 9 F 6 by 2 Paul of Knight to c3
g6 Bishop to e3
we have Bishop to g7 Queen to d2
we have c6 f 3 b5 not GTE to Knight B to
d7 and now power plays Bishop to h6 and
here to Paolo captures Bishop captures
on h6 and Queen captures on h6 and this
is okay for Kasparov as it will stop the
ball from ever castling kingside
but the power doesn't mind he was
considering a queenside castle anyway so
we have Bishop to b7 we have a three by
Kasparov cuz power
Kasparov decides not to Castle just yet
he considers a three is a better move
here so we have e five by Topalov and
now cos power of castles we have Queen
to e7 and King b1 just getting his King
to a safer square so we have a six by
top all of this a six move kind of
prevents the white from playing d5 and
weakening this b5 pawn so to power plays
a6 preparing to castle himself and
Kasparov place and I'd see 491 because
well cuz power really wants to get this
Knight to a5 as this a6 move
really really makes a nice square for
the 1985 so to follow a castles Queen
side we have Knight to b3 and now top
all place he captures on d4 we have
characters on d4 and now c5 and as power
plays rook to d1 so we have nice to b6
preparing that d5 if black ever plays d5
the power will be very happy about this
and it took a sparrow of some I think 12
minutes to figure out his next move and
he decided to play g3 and what this g3
move does Casper wants to get this
Knight to a5 he wants to put this Bishop
on h3 and this strong diagonal and he
wants to play Queen to f4 and with this
idea all of whites pieces will be
pointing to the direction of the black
king so the power plays King to be 8 and
here we have Knight to a5 we have Bishop
to a 8 so the bishop can be captured by
the night and now power plays Bishop to
h3 continuing with his plan and here at
Apollo does push d5 so we have a queen
to a Queen to f4 check by Kasparov and
here the power plays King to a 7 and now
Kasparov plays rook H 2 e 1 and now all
of Kasparov species are in ideal places
and here Kasparov was already actually
calculating a very nice idea and Apollo
allows it he plays d4 and he played D
for feeling quite satisfied so this is
Kasparov's idea because power plays
Knight to d5 attacking the Queen and
going for that exchange of knights to
remove one more defender from the King
so we have knife captors and e5e captors
on d5 and this opens up an attack on the
Queen and now here to power plays Queen
to d6 offering to exchange Queens and
this is actually the position because
Peres was hoping for
he said that well this could easily be a
but he says that in his mind he was
thinking of the game between Edward
Lasker and Sir Thomas you know the one
with the nice King walk I have it
covered on my channel if you haven't
seen it so here a sparrow actually plays
rook captures on d4 and as soon as
Kasparov played this rook captures and
before he got out of he got off the
table and started walking around and he
was calculating all sorts of lines in
his head and he says that it suddenly
shocked him what if what if the power
plays King to b6 King to b6 was probably
ruin every idea cuz part of head but
this is why Kasparov says that Caixa was
kind to him that day he was playing
playing a game against the Veselin
Topalov who isn't interested in playing
a move like King to b6 also a great
attacker himself and while playing King
b6 but the well be something like
admitting that he missed rook captures
than before so here at Apollo captures
here - Paul captures broken before and
this is the point of this entire
combination cuz power plays rook to e7
and one more thing I want you to know
that this entire idea of rook rook
captures and d4 is possible only because
this rook is on h8 if this rook was an
idea any other square but h8 then this
would not be possible but you'll see
what I mean by this later
so Kasparov lays a rook to e7 check and
well although this wasn't a surprise the
table all of its it's a very nice idea
let's see what happens if the pollo
captures the second rook if Queen
captures on e7 you would get Queen
captures on d4 with check King to b8
Queen to b6 with check you have to block
this Bishop to b7 and now Knight to c6
check and this is for King the king and
queen but that doesn't really matter as
you can see this bishop here is
protecting c8 so the King gets to go to
a eight and this would be Queen to a7
checkmate so after this rook to e7 check
top all of instantly we played Kingdom
six and here Kasparov plays Queen
Catherine before would check and this is
what he meant when he was thinking about
the game between Edward Lasker and Sir
Thomas he is taking the King for a nice
walk so the power plays King captures on
a five here we have before by Kasparov
and we have Kings to a four byte Apollo
and thus power plays Quincy 3 and this
is a this is a deadly move as it's a
threatening Queen to b3 checkmate so
this has to be defended somehow and the
power of plays Queen captures on d5
protecting the be three square wood is
Queen and here the power plays rook to
a7 also a very nice move and now
threatening rook captures on a6 with
checkmate and it's really not a simple
task to stop this I mean you could try a
lot of things the Queen can't move from
here to protect it with the Queen
because then Queen b3 checkmate is
available again if you try something
like rook to d6 to prevent checkmate it
this way well this leads actually to a
very beautiful idea that is king to be 2
and now Queen to b3 check is unstoppable
followed by a C capture son b3 with
checkmate so only move would be
something like Queen to d4 and here cuz
para would simply capture the Queen and
the pollo cannot capture back because
rook captures an a6 is checkmate again
so after this rook a7 idea to Paulo
finds a bishop to b7 protecting the
point this way so Kasparov captures it
route rook captures and b7 and the power
plays Queen to c4 so this lost as part
of to capture this knight on f6 and here
because Baro is also threatening Queen
captures and a6 with checkmate
so the power has to capture this pawn on
a3 going even deeper with the King so we
have Queen captures an a6 with check and
we have King captures in b4 and this is
the position to Paolo says that he saw
when Kasparov sacrificed the rook but
the ball of missed the c3 move if the
palace had seen the Citroen c3 move he
probably would have played King visa
and one for a draw but he missed this so
what happens if the Queen captures if
the Queen captures in c3 well it's
simply Queen captures and b5 would check
King gay 3 and wrote a 7 this is deadly
because Queen to a5 and rook captures
done if a 5 is checkmate so on c3 topple
has to capture with the King King
captures on c3 and now we have this very
nice Queen to a1 check by Kasparov and
now the King cannot go to d3 because of
Bishop to f1 check picking up the Queen
so the power plays King to d2 and now we
have Queen to be to check and the top
ala plays King to d1 and it seems that
the attack is over for Kasparov but now
you see this Bishop and h3 as it usually
is is well he didn't really do that much
in the game but his presence was well
known in every line Kasparov used in the
attack and now as usual with great
attackers this light square Bishop comes
into the attack just in the right moment
so Bishop to f1 and this is deadly the
queen is attacked and the Queen has
nowhere to go if the Queen ever moves
from this diagonal then Queen to e2
checkmate is coming so let's see what
happens if Queen captures the bishop if
Queen captures an f1 we have Quinta see
to check King to e1 and rook to e7 check
and the King has no squares to go
the Queen has the block and this is
checkmate so on Bishop f1 Topalov tries
one more counter blow and it seems as he
found the way out of this he plays rook
to d2 now attacking Kasparov's Queen but
as far Oh again continues the attack in
great style and plays rook to d7
sacrificing this rook finally and
pinning this works of the Queen can be
captured so the pollo captures the rook
and here top all of parts with this
Queen and we have a Bishop to c4 and
this is what you remember when I told
you that the the entire idea of rook
captures and D for the rook sacrifice
was possible because this rook was an h8
now you will see why casparo captures
the Queen with Bishop captures and c4
and he's threatening Queen to eat -
checkmate
and if black would try to stop this for
example with playing rook to e8 to
defend the e2 square then
casparo would have this very nice Queen
to c1 checkmate so the only move for the
pollo here is to capture the bishop so
he captures on c4 and now Kasparov
finally picks up this rook on h8 so
Queen captures on h8 so a very nice
point to this line we have work to do
- pollo will continue this game and try
to fight it out but casparo finishes it
very nicely we have Queen to 8c3
now Queen to a4 check we have King te 1
and now F for not allowing to follow up
any counter play we have f5 and now
Kasparov place King to c1 denying any
hope this C pawn might have of becoming
a queen we have rook to d2 going for
that h2 pawn and here Kasparov plays
Queen - Queen to a7 and in this position
- pollo resigned the the white queen
will gobble up all of these pawns and
the rook cannot capture this pawn on h2
because of Quinta g1 check picking up
the rook so in this position
Gary top I mean vessel it Apollo
resigned and yeah it's a it's a very
interesting game as the pol of plate
that appears defense just the surprise
Kasparov so both players were on unknown
terms and like Kasparov says it's good
that Caixa was kind to him that day
because topalov could have easily gone
for a draw if you refuse the roof
sacrifice but luckily he was playing
none other than vessel into power that
day and so this beautiful game was
accomplished
although top olive did help to create it
so yeah this is the game and the reason
I decided to show one more game by
Kasparov is that August is almost here
and well one more chance to see the
beast of Baku return to chess and play
some great games in Saint
so yeah that's it as usual you can check
to my previous videos here and I would
also like to thank people who continue
to contribute to my channel
Thank You Phil Colville and thank you
thank you William Shaffer Meier you guys
are great and really thanks for all your
support and yeah that's it thank you for
watching and I will see you soon Oh